merci la parole est au président
christian jacob merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président je sais
qu'un hommage sera rendu à charles
pasqua au sénat mais permettez-moi
dernière assemblée où il a siégé mais
permettez moi au nom de mon groupe
d'avoir une pensée émue pour celui qui
fut un grand patriote et un grand
serviteur de l'état
mc
merci merci monsieur le président donne
ma voix et merci également à vous
monsieur le premier ministre au
gouvernement à tous nos collègues qui
ont salué la mémoire de cet homme d'état
monsieur le premier ministre ma question
s'adresse à vous monsieur le premier
ministre
un homme un innocent un français dignes
et droits est mort décapité au nom de
l'islamisme radical qui nous a déclaré
la guerre pour tous les français cet
acte de barbarie est insoutenable
c'est une guerre une guerre contre notre
civilisation judéo-chrétienne une guerre
contre la civilisation des lumières dont
la france est l'héritière
face à haas est un ennemi qui s'attaque
à nos valeurs les plus profondes
nous avons un devoir d'unité d'unité
derrière nos soldats engagés au sahel au
moyen orient pour défendre nos libertés
unité derrière nos policiers derrière
nos gendarmes derrière nos services
partout remarquable ici à l'assemblée
l'opposition n'a jamais manqué monsieur
le premier ministre à son devoir d'unité
à trois reprises nous avons voté les
textes que vous nous avez soumis en
décembre 2012 en 2014 et tout récemment
le texte sur le renseignement
mais aujourd'hui monsieur le premier
ministre nous vous demandons
solennellement d'aller plus loin pour
pour ne pas perdre cette guerre il faut
s'en donner effectivement les moyens
d'abord avec un collectif budgétaire
pour affecter à nos services les moyens
dont ils ont besoin dans la durée
ensuite un volet répressif puissant qui
permettra l'enfermement des individus
radicalisés au départ et au retour du
djihad et enfin la déchéance de
nationalité et l'expulsion des
binationaux qui ont porté les armes
contre la france
ceux qui combattaient qui salissent le
drapeau français ne mérite pas d'être
français ma question est donc simple
monsieur le premier ministre au moment
où les français attendent de nous que
nous soyons unis est intraitable face à
nos ennemis
allez vous retenir nos propositions la
parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls se le président
jacob près dans la république moi même
plusieurs membres du gouvernement ont
salué la mémoire de charles pasqua
nous avons en mémoire les mots de
françois mitterrand
concernant charles pasqua et personne
ici ne peut oublier au delà des
différences et du parcours de charles
pasqua qui fut gaulliste qu'il avait une
certaine idée de la république et de la
france et qu'il fut un des plus jeunes
résistants de notre pays et vous avez
raison il faut honorer la mémoire de
charles pasqua
que jacob je remercie de votre question
parce que c'est vrai que nous avons tous
dit ici d'une manière ou d'une autre
nous sommes confrontés à la sans doute
la plus grande menace de ces dernières
décennies celle de ce terrorisme et de
cet adversaire à la fois extérieur et
intérieur c'est le même ce sont les
mêmes terroristes qui agissent à
l'extérieur ici ou dans d'autres pays
je donnais les chiffres tout à l'heure
au nom de ce devoir de vérité et de
lucidité
je rappelais où je rappelle une nouvelle
fois que d'autres pays sont concernés
par ces phénomènes la plupart en europe
ayez un chiffre qui est effrayant et qui
doit nous amener à mesurer l'ampleur de
ce phénomène
ce sont aujourd'hui c'est 5000 européen
je ne parle que des européens qui sont
présents en irak ou en syrie les
projections pour la fin de l'année
prévoit dix mille européen au delà de ce
qu'ils tunisiens marocains ou algériens
sont déjà là bas
chacun doit donc comprendre et je
l'avais fait à la tribune de cette
assemblée le 13 janvier dernier mais
déjà dès la fin de l'année 2012
quand nous avions voté ensemble la
première loi antiterroriste qui tiraient
aussi les leçons de des crimes de mera à
toulouse et à montauban
donc oui nous sommes engagés dans une
guerre contre le terrorisme de guerre
que même le terrorisme une guerre qui
notamment celle de dèche qui est
nouvelle
par rapport au phénomène de terrorisme
que nous avons connue et pour cela il
faut évidemment des moyens nouveaux et
considérable notre arsenal juridique et
la gelée rappeler ce sont les deux lois
antiterroristes avec des mesures
concrètes efficaces qu'il faut appliquer
tous les jours la loi renseignements
devant le conseil constitutionnel
aujourd'hui et qui nous donne des moyens
supplémentaires je ne sais pas c'est
difficile à dire et je pense notamment à
la famille de notre compatriote
mais je reste convaincu avec le ministre
de l'intérieur que les moyens que nous
donne ces lois aurait peut-être et je
suis prudent permis de mieux savoir ce
que préparait cet individu donc nous
avons besoin de ces moyens nous avons
besoin d'une coopération européenne bien
sûr elle est indispensable majeur et
avec l'adoption du pnr au plus vite
pour ce fichier recensant les passagers
sur les vols et que chaque parlementaire
européens se rendent bien compte que
tous les pays d'europe et les citoyens
qui aujourd'hui à juste titre ont peur
du terrorisme que chaque parlementaire
européen prenne ses responsabilités et
que le parlement européen puisse enfin
voter le plein air parce que c'est aussi
les instruments ils auront besoin de
cette coopération avec les pays en
europe nous l'avons engagé avec bernard
cazeneuve avec tous les pays qui sont
concernés et il faut que l'europe la
france elle prend ses responsabilités ed
la tunisie car la tunisie est un pays
ami est un pays frère victimes du
terrorisme parce que c'est ce pays qui a
enclenché cette véritable démocratie
c'est un pays qui porte haut les valeurs
de la démocratie et de la ligue et de la
laïcité
c'est aussi pour cela que ce pays frère
a été attaqué par les terroristes et
nous devons et nous avons un devoir de
soutien comme l'a fait le ministre de
l'intérieur hier où se rendant avec ses
homologues allemand et britannique
nous avons mis les moyens peut toujours
en faire plus c'est monsieur le
président jacob comme nous l'avons
montré à l'occasion de cette réunion ce
matin à l'elysée autour du chef de
l'état nous sommes nous toujours
disponible pour examiner vos
propositions et aller plus loin je
rappelais le nombre de policiers de
gendarmes et de militaires mobilisés
je peux rappeler aussi les 1830
policiers et gendarmes supplémentaires
dédiées à la lutte contre le terrorisme
qui ont été créés en trois ans dont 930
au sein du renseignement intérieur les
250 millions d'euros engagés les 950
emplois qui se mettent en oeuvre va
aller toujours plus vite bien sûr il
faut des hommes et des femmes formées
dans les juridictions spécialisées dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme et le
milieu pénitentiaire parce qu'il faut
poursuivre sans relâche cette action
tous les jours le libère tous les jours
des filières des individus sont
démantelés war étaient six attentats
majeurs ont été évités depuis 2013 des
filières ont été démantelées
ces derniers jours quatorze personnes
ont été interpellées nous continuerons
les expulsions
c'est indispensable bien sûr de
prêcheurs de haine et de terroristes en
fin de peine dont 10 imams gelé rappeler
la déchéance de la nationalité dans des
conditions de respect du droit
nous y sommes prêts ça n'avait jamais
été fait à ce niveau là nous
continuerons mais la lucidité
monsieur le président et je sais que sur
ces questions
nous retrouver nous amène aussi à voir
qu'il y à des compatriotes pas des
binationaux qu'il ya comme dans beaucoup
de pays également des convertis et
notamment au salafisme dans un certain
nombre de quartiers donc nous devons
agir dans tous les paramètres en
rassemblant la société française la
laïcité l'école la manière dont on vit
les quartiers parce qu'au fond c'est ça
qui se joue si je suis inquiet comme
voulait comme le sont évidemment
aujourd'hui les français parce qu'au
fond ils se disent mais aujourd'hui mon
voisin il peut être un terroriste c'est
ça qui est en train de changer
à l'émotion du mois de janvier
aujourd'hui c'est la peur qui s'est
emparée si nous voulons pas que ça soit
la peur qui s'impose dans notre société
alors nous devons être forts et monsieur
le président jacob moi je ne vous donne
rendez-vous pour examiner ensemble les
solutions que nous pouvons mettre en
oeuvre dans le strict respect de l'état
de droit avec les moyens nécessaires
mais avec le ministre de l'intérieur
avec la garde des sceaux
nous sommes ouverts au dialogue parce
que j'ai une conviction profonde
l'unité l'unité le rassemblement des
français autour des valeurs est plus que
jamais indispensable face à ce qui est
une véritable guerre merci monsieur le
premier ministre